hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm Joan so today we're gonna watch
another trailer for Fifty Shades freed
this is grey will see you now
oh man I should've brought my collar I
wish you all good I wish you did in my
crop oh where you goin G you going to
your to your sex dungeon it's very
uncomfortable oh my oh you've actually
got fun yeah what is that a flogger yeah
just on myself anyway sure video
response to will appreciate that
today's race is sponsored by nether then
start us start us is this awesome app
that allows you to 30-second reactions
or reviews for any film TV show or
trailer trying to get to 4000 followers
as soon as possible right now
a lot of your favorite youtubers are
using including Tyrone Magnus and the
flick pick we love using the app or
using a frequently poster out the week
so download the app and follow us first
woo you gotta use that in your starters
review of this a that murder sup what
looks like it's gonna be heavily
Kim Basinger that's right tripping over
the floor
it's from the older and as we're walking
down memory lane the led to their
beautiful marriage
I've had hotter than a husband and wife
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you may call me mrs. gray you're rich
now is Marvel shop oh yeah
[Music]
the brothers though I will barely be in
the movie
[Music]
I think you do safe first long as we
both shall live
[Music]
set up for the next trip horny that kid
grows up to be
you got like sex dungeon mom and dad who
were still at least the last time I
checked it on I'm still trying to figure
out the balance of that plus you got
people always coming in trying to break
up their relationships trying to kill
them like that kid's gonna have messed
up why they have twins who start mating
with each other oh that's what I'm
hoping for you gotta take the edginess
to the next level right there people you
know take the edginess to the next level
well as usual this movie looks like
nothing I got quite a kick out of the
the last movie I actually enjoyed it not
because Detroit cuz I felt like I
actually knew what it was I have a new
it's about nothing I don't know I might
it's nonsense seriously enough I'm
willing to sit through this movie in the
theaters I skipped out on the last one
the theatres I'm willing to sit through
this just laugh and get mildly turned on
omit like sometimes the sexual stuff is
kind of sexy sexy sometimes it was
pretty sexy you're like ooh and I'm like
mildly turned on but then I'm also aware
of how stupid this whole I enjoy it I
enjoy the movie it's it's fun I would
never say it's like this is boring and
and for that alone it earned some points
in my book this movie right here looks
like more of the same actually feels
less sexual because they're married but
yeah when you're married it takes away a
lot of the sexual tension flare and a
lot of the taboo stuff because the whole
point now is like yeah we don't keep
anything from you yeah we're just gonna
be really open about our fetishes and
you know I guess it'll be fine I would
like them to try to have a hard time
keeping their marriage
if that would be a more intriguing plot
to me as like oh now that we're married
and together because it seems like this
this movie has the opportunity to take
advantage of like the psychological term
turmoil you know how like a lot of
people are drawn to the ones who are
emotionally unavailable or unhealthy for
them like how these two are you can kind
of dive into like the backgrounds of
abuse upbringing this movie's not gonna
do any of that no especially for
Anastasia might do a little bit of that
more for Christian but somehow they
tease in the last one you got Kim
Basinger back here all the thriller
elements of like someone's gonna kill me
I know is gonna barely be in this film
cuz that's how they do all that I'm
loading a gun dude see this and know
they have to go they'll think there's
gonna be something even look at the
r-rating there's nothing about violence
and it's our rating even though the
trailer just to make it seem there's
gonna be peril and danger - sort of like
rentals that you have to watch it the
theater I enjoy it on that scale but I
enjoy it more when there are other
people around yeah reason like and these
movies having seen the first two and
looking at this I've realized there's
like a weird lack of concept of time for
me yeah like I'd never feel like I'm
checking it with characters on a journey
or in the midst of Arc's every 50 shades
of gray feels like Evil Dead 2 to me or
it's like it's kind of the first one
just a little bit updated yeah basically
like the premise is the same and yeah
you know you just watch them argue about
a couple things
hook up a bunch of times then someone
tries to shake up their relationship and
that's the end yeah yeah there's
especially this one felt the most
vanilla out of all their trailers I was
like oh oh yeah I forgot like she's not
that kinky actually and they're just
gonna you know tie each other up and
moan a lot and we're gonna see a lot of
close-up angles of him rubbing like
crops against her skin or whatever great
do you know what I just realized what it
is on IMAX I one day wonder maybe they
shot all the sex scenes and
I max 70 millimeter cameras you can see
the the CG bush you know three stories
high yeah subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification bell make sure to
download and follow us first on the
Stardust app and please check out our
patreon it's like a second youtube
channel over there people always I have
a lot of fun post a lot of videos over
there check us out
check us you